In the African wilderness, a wild beast desecrates
your loved ones’ graves, and spawns disease
and blight with just a glance in your direction.
Able to wander essentially undetected among
people during the day, at night it transforms
into a terrifying creature—the werehyena.
Associated with death, gluttony, and greed,
this monster joins the ranks of werewolves,
selkies, and other shapeshifting monsters.
Werecreatures—humans or animals that can
shapeshift from one form into another—are
common across the globe, taking different
forms based on the real predators in the local
area.
Most familiar to a western audience is the
werewolf, but given that there are four different
species of hyena in Africa, it’s not so
surprising that the version of the monster
we find in that continent looks more like
this than this.
There’s way more to these monsters than
in the Buffy episode.
So let’s look at the werehyena of African
folklore.
And how the Beta Israel religious group became
commonly accused of taking the guise of this
monster.
[Monstrum intro.]
A werehyena is most commonly believed to be
a hyena masquerading by day as a human, as
opposed to the more western figure of a werewolf,
which is a human who turns into a wolf, usually
at night.
A werehyena’s human skin is the false one,
and while a werehyena in human form may be
noticed by an unusually hairy body or nasally
voice, more often than not they can walk among
humans unnoticed.
In the wild plains of Africa, hyenas stand
out as repugnant animals.
Though often thought of merely as opportunistic
scavengers, in reality their cunning tactics,
knife-like teeth, and surprising swiftness
make these animals formidable foes.
Hyenas are often considered the outsiders
of the animal world characterized as unnatural
and disgusting since they consume rotten flesh,
and associated with greed since they steal
the kills of other animals.
While they won’t turn their nose down at
rotting flesh, hyenas are intelligent hunters
capable of taking down wildebeest and antelope.
Add in a human skinsuit so it can wander among
us by day and you have yourself one terrifying
monster.
In Sudan, Tanzania, Ethiopia, and some parts
of Morocco and Eritrea werehyena
are associated with groups of outsiders who
are accused of possessing magical abilities
and the powerful stare of an evil eye.
Called, Buda or bouda, a derogatory
title, Buda are thought to control animal
spirits intentionally or unintentionally,
cause illness, poison people’s food and
-- shapeshift into a hyena.
Buda and werehyenas are most often associated
with artisan trades like metal working, weaving,
and pottery and their evil powers are said
to be passed on from generation to generation,
much like skills of a trade.
Almost all Buda are described as “landless
people.”
And the people most commonly associated with
landlessness and of being smiths and potters
in eastern Africa are the Ethiopian Jews.
Self -identifying as the Beta Israel, this
group is a religious and professional minority
in the largely Christian country of Ethiopia
that coalesced into a more unified group by
the 15th century.
Origins of the group’s faith are hotly debated
in scholarship, but what is generally agreed
upon is that the group started in one of the
so called “heretic” communities in Ethiopia.
People outside of the group called the Beta
Israel “Ayhud” or “Falasha,” which
at their base meaning, refers to Jews and
the Jewish community but are also synonymous
with “exiles” and those who practiced
“magic.”
Both terms are considered derogatory.
The derogatory name Falasha as a designator
for the Beta Israel first became a widespread
term in the 16th century onward.
By then, the definition of a Falasi is a landless
person, a wanderer, an exile.
So how and why did the Beta Israel become
associated with werehyenas?
In the late 15th and early 16th century, the
masonry and carpentry skills of the Beta Israel
were highly valued.
Their contributions to infrastructure and
architecture led to a rise in their economic
and social mobility.
They were also noted soldiers in the imperial
army.
Their rewards for their skills on and off
the battlefield even led to the gifting of
titles and land to the Beta Israel, which
if you remember, directly contradicts the
definition of Buda.
Then in 1769 Ethiopia, Emperor Iyo’as was
assassinated, causing political and social
upheaval, and pushing marginalized peoples,
including the Beta Israel, into other trades
like pottery and smithing.
It also placed their religious practices under
attack.
These new craft professions of the Beta Israel—smithery
for the men, and pottery for the women—had
one big thing in common.
Fire.
Across history fire is associated with magic,
because what’s more magical than using fire
to transform a seemingly useless material—like
iron or clay—into a knife or a bowl?
Christians believed Beta Israel's superior
skills were supernatural.
It is an almost universal theme in African
cultures that metalworkers, like the Buda,
are associated with malevolent spellcraft.
Such artisans are often “landless” moving
from place to place as necessary for their
profession, leasing farming land as tenants
from Christian landholders.
Their more nomadic lifestyle alienated them
from permanent residents, and cast suspicion
upon their motives.
And people began to wonder, could these individuals
practicing crafts with such transformative
powers be able to transform their bodies as
well?
Christians of the day chose a dramatic way
to “other” the community and claimed all
the Ethiopian Jews were Buda—designating
them dangerous.
In fact, many Christians actually believed
the Beta Israel assumed human disguises during
the day, and returned to their natural hyena
form during the night.
Very different from other types of werecreatures
in global lore, most famously the werewolf,
instead of a human turning into an animal,
these werehyenas were animals that shapeshifted
into humans.
Another bit of anti-Semetic lore further stigmatized
Beta Israel blacksmiths, claiming they descended
from the Jewish smith who crafted the nails
used to crucify Jesus.
This accusation further classified the Beta
Israel as Buda.
Some people even began referring to them as
the “Hyena People” an association that
equated them with an animal largely seen as
disgusting.
These continuing prejudices saw blood libel
accusations, the allegations of the ritual
murder of Christians and the Beta Israel were
charged with turning into hyenas and draining
the blood of their victims by vampiric means,
or by afflicting them with an illness that
required medical blood letting.
Buda werehyena lore asserts that this blood
was used for rituals, medicine, and nutrition.
In modern Ethiopia, buda is still a derogatory,
alienating insult.
And nowadays it's illegal to accuse someone
of being a werehyena.
Werecreature folklore exists across the globe,
and in my observation, the werehyena is unique
in its direct connection to a specific religious
group.
The relationship between werehyenas, Buda,
and the Beta Israel gives us yet another example
of how outsider groups are demonized by people
in positions of power, and who perpetuate
myths like this one as a means of social control
to keep those deemed as “monstrous” oppressed.